we're told to look at the following
number line and this number line we
actually have times on it so you could
even call it a timeline we're starting
at one o'clock here then we go to 1 15 1
30 1 45 then 2 o'clock
and it says what time is shown on the
number line so pause this video and see
if you can figure that out
alright so the hour i think is pretty
straightforward we are past one o'clock
but we are before two o'clock so we know
that the hour is going to be one
something it's not going to be two
something because we haven't gotten to
two o'clock yet
now what is the number of minutes after
one o'clock
well we have a hint here it's going to
be between 15
and 30 and where would it be
well one way to tell is if you look at
each of these tick marks it looks like
they represent a minute let's just count
if we start at 1 we go to 101 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 15. yup it looks like each
of these tick marks is a minute so we
just have to figure out how many tick
marks we are past 115
so we can see that we can go from
15 to 16 17 18 19 20
21 22 23 24 25 so we're 25 minutes past
one o'clock
another way you could have thought about
it is
each of these
medium tick marks represent five minutes
and you can count one two three four
five so that's five that's another five
so this time right over here is going to
be five plus five is ten it's going to
be 10 minutes past 115 well 15 plus 10
is 25 again so the time shown on the
number line is 125